qué tal bienvenido de regreso en el
vídeo pasado les hablé un poco acerca de
cómo hacer como un inverso de la regla
de la cadena para utilizarla para
resolver integrales esto también se
puede hacer con una técnica que se llama
integración por sustitución esto es
esencialmente el inverso de la regla de
la cadena vamos a ver el último problema
que hicimos es decir la integral la
integral de seno de x elevado al cubo x
coseno de x y todo eso de x
ahora en el vídeo pasado lo que hice fue
dar una explicación pues muy informal de
que estábamos invirtiendo la regla de la
cadena y entonces lo que hacíamos era
ver la derivada de seno hacia afuera que
es coseno entonces podríamos tratar a
seno de x como una función aparte
entonces simplemente les dije que eso de
ahí era igual a seno de x
seno de x elevado a la cuarta x un
cuarto
la razón por la cual simplemente
podríamos tratarse no como una función
aparte es porque encontrábamos su
derivada aquí afuera bueno si hacemos
esto de ida y de regreso con la regla de
la cadena y su inversa va todo va a
tener más sentido pero puede ser un poco
confuso de todas formas entonces te voy
a enseñar una técnica que se llama
integración por sustitución que es
exactamente lo mismo pero es un poco más
metódico y va a ser un poco más claro
supongamos que no conocemos la respuesta
y vamos a empezar aquí abajo entonces
supongamos que tenemos una función y su
derivada entonces lo que vamos a hacer
es renombrar esa función entonces vamos
a decir sea o igual a la función seno de
x talento es lo primero que hacemos es
decir sea igual a seno de x va y ahora
el siguiente paso es derivar un derivado
con respecto a qué pues derivamos o con
respecto a x la derivada está fácil
verdad ya sabemos que la derivada de
seno es coseno entonces le ponemos
coseno de x
verdad eso lo aprendimos eso lo
aprendimos antes tal vez después lo
demuestra en un vídeo posterior pero
ahora lo que vamos a hacer es sustituir
estas dos cosas en la integral de acá
arriba entonces nos queda la integral de
en vez de escribir seno de equis tenemos
que escribir y entonces nos queda al
cubo y que es cosa de equis pues ya
vimos que coseno de x es de entre de x
entonces voy a poner por aquí por dv
/ de x y todavía nos falta una cosita
todavía hay que poner el de x multiplicó
por de x listo entonces miren lo que voy
a hacer es cancelar este de x de aquí a
lo mejor no estamos muy cómodos con eso
porque no sabemos cómo tratar los
diferenciales pero si se comportan más o
menos como las fracciones entonces vamos
a tachar las los vamos a cancelar y
entonces lo que nos queda es la integral
de cuál cubo de eeuu y esta integral y
está súper fácil
esta es una que ya habías visto sólo que
en vez de tener x tiene una entonces
vamos a resolverla con un entonces lo
vamos a poner aquí abajo
es igual a 114 de uva la cuarta
más se sale entonces ya terminamos bueno
pues sí más o menos pero estaría bueno
regresarlo todo a términos de x porque
así empezamos entonces déjenme pasar
todo a términos de x por acá
entonces pues simplemente seno de x
entonces nos queda un cuarto de seno de
x elevado a la cuarta más c y listo ya
quedó de hecho está como ves es una
mejor forma de escribir eso del inverso
de la regla de la cadena pero bueno ya
ni modo ya viste el otro vídeo ya eso y
eso pasa cuando me siguen la corriente
ahora vamos a hacer otro problema más
vamos a hacer otros dos problemas más a
ver déjenme poner una nueva pantalla y
vamos a resolver la integral
vamos a resolver la integral de 2 x + 3
multiplicado x pues digamos x cuadrada
más 3 x más 15
y esta expresión elevada la puesta la
quinta potencia de x
estoy ahí se ve un poco complicado
verdad pero justo como dijimos es un
patrón que tenemos que encontrar aquí
tenemos esta expresión aquí adentro
adentro de elevar a la quinta verdad
pero cuál es la derivada de x cuadrada
más 3x más 15 pues justo el 2x más 3 si
te das cuenta que escucharía el
ejercicio para que justo saliera verdad
entonces no te preocupes eso es lo que
hacen casi todos los libros y casi todos
los maestros pues hagamos la sustitución
aquí está nuestra hubo entonces la que
proponemos es igual a x cuadrada más 3 x
más 15
y entonces quién es de uno tenemos que
derivar entonces vamos a poner dvd equis
y eso es igual a 2 x 3 el 15 cuando lo
derivamos que hace 0 entonces podemos
hacer las sustituciones nos queda la
integral pero va a cambiar estos dos de
orden entonces esto de la derecha es a
la quinta porque es x cuadrada más 13 x
más 15 entonces nos queda a la quinta y
aquí tenemos de v / de x entonces le
ponemos por de uno entre de x
simplemente cambia el orden verdad
entonces hay que multiplicar todavía por
un de x ahora si te incomoda esto de
cancelar los de x no te preocupes es
algo que te va que les incomoda a los
matemáticos hasta que aprenden cosas muy
avanzadas por el momento vamos a suponer
que si se puede hacer eso y vamos a
seguirle por acá entonces esto es igual
a la integral de a la quinta vez y esta
entrega al de aquí ya está muy fácil
esto es simplemente igual a un sexto de
las seis más c
sale entonces ya podemos regresar a
términos de x lo voy a poner por acá
para que quede así super desordenado
entonces nos queda un sexto de uno que
es esta expresión
entonces nos queda x cuadrada más 3 x
más 15 todo eso a la sexta potencia y
que no se nos olvide el más listo
acabamos con este vamos a hacer un
ejemplo más nos queda tiempo para uno
más vamos a borrar la imagen invertimos
los colores sales
y voy a ponerlo ahora con color azul hoy
vamos a tomar la integral vamos a tomar
la integral d
pues digamos de la equis multiplicado
pobre a la equis creo que aquí más o
menos ves que estoy intentando hacer y
esto lo voy a evaluar a la quinta no
mejora algo negativo a la menos tres
sale de equis
ok entonces una vez más fíjate que aquí
tenemos una expresión a la equis y cuál
es su derivada pues sus derivadas a la
equis entonces las cosas que no dejan de
sorprenderme de la función a la equis
que cuando la derivamos se queda igual
de hecho esa es una definición para él
es el número tal que la función es el
número a la equis y cuando se deriva
queda igual pero bueno ahorita no quiero
meter mucho en tantos detalles pero
vamos a proponer igual a la equis y
entonces veo entre de equis la derivada
es la equis también verdad entonces
vamos a reescribir esta expresión aquí
arriba a la derecha eso es igual
este de aquí es de 1 / b x
x
a la menos tres de ellos para lo mejor
estás pensando porque pusiste un dvd x
en una idea la equis y el otro en la uv
y por qué no lo hicimos al revés digamos
que el primero era un y por qué no
dijimos que pues digamos que el segundo
era de 1 / x es decir porque no puse
aquí adentro
dv / de x elevado a la menos 3 de x pero
si te das cuenta eso no sirve de nada
porque no se va a poder cancelar la de
xy entonces va a quedar muy complicado
la vista me estoy dando cuenta que el
ejemplo podría simplificarse un poquito
antes de empezar pero ahorita hablamos
de eso dejar lo pasamos al final ahorita
seguimos con esto la sustitución de este
x de esta forma se complican las cosas y
entonces regresemos a la original aquí
arriba así podemos cancelar y entonces
queda la integral de la menos 3 b y esa
de ahí ya está fácil es a ver hay que
sumarle 1 al exponente entonces es menos
un medio de uala menos 2
y eso es lo mismo que menos un medio d
a la equis elevado a la menos dos y
bueno utilizando leyes de los exponentes
podemos verlo como menos un medio de al
menos dos hechos y por supuesto más
entonces esta es la respuesta a que me
refería con lo de la simplificación
bueno fíjate en esto de acá aquí podemos
utilizar las leyes de los exponentes
desde el principio así nos queda a la x
x a la menos 3x px y una vez más usando
leyes de los exponentes nos queda a la
menos 2x ahora está ya que a lo mejor no
sean inmediatamente claro cómo hacerla
pero si es un poco más fácil después
hablaremos de eso bueno esto es un
problema estos son algunos problemas de
cómo utilizar sustitución pero después
espero hacer un vídeo con algunos
ejemplos un poco más complicados de esta
técnica para que sigamos practicando en
esto nos vemos pronto